[Music]
it's national flag day in ukraine
president kolovy mercelenski attended a
ceremony to honor the symbol of the
fight against the invasion
cities across the east and south have
been occupied by russia ukraine is
fighting to get them back
we will never recognize someone's colors
on our land and in our sky
we're always ready to defend our blue
and yellow flag
i asked now to commemorate heroes who
gave their lives for those scholars with
a moment of silence
ukraine is also marking 31 years of
independence from soviet rule
the government has displayed russian
tanks and are more vehicles that have
been destroyed during the past six
months ukrainian officials say moscow
had been hoping to hold a military
parade in central key to celebrate its
victory
but this is what they got instead
vera vaclan is confident her country
will prevail we pray every single moment
for the war to be over we believe in our
army and
we're sure it's going to be over
with our victory but it just depends on
the time
ukraine is on high alert president
celensky says vladimir putin is plotting
fresh assaults and u.s intelligence
agencies have warned russia may be
planning strikes against government
buildings or civilian infrastructure
kiwi is far from the front line and has
only rarely been hit by russian missiles
since ukrainian forces managed to push
russian soldiers out of the city back in
march but authorities are cautious
they're
banning public gatherings and are asking
people to take the air raid sirens very
seriously
since february thousands of people have
been displaced injured and killed
pusha is a reminder of the atrocities
russian forces committed in their
attempt to take the capital
father andrei says he's still helping to
bury the remains found in mass graves
across the town
i think that neither i know anyone who
lives in ukraine who witnessed the war
can understand what happened for now we
are surviving on adrenaline but after
everything that's happened i'm worried
that the aftermath will last decades
six months on ukrainians are fighting
for survival against an enemy that is
unwilling to retreat
there is